hey everybody
this is Ryan and tureen today we're
gonna make the stylus I'm here with Rudy
and Eli or Eli and Rudy and how you want
to look at it it's just a twist on a
classic 50/50 martini we're gonna start
with an ounce and a half of the Bombay
Sapphire gin okay so gin is gonna go in
the dis guy that's somebody will be
paying attention whoa this is what it's
going it's going into magic I think he's
gonna get right yep bounce and a half of
the Bombay Sapphire pour that right into
your pint glass we're gonna do 3/4 an
ounce of a traditional dry vermouth I
definitely recommend oily prep original
French dry they get very nice we're
gonna do 3/4 an ounce of a traditional
vermouth oh there go in your mouth yes
3/4 an ounce right in there we're gonna
do 1/4 of an ounce of a medium dry
sherry all right now you just you've
given up I like it
that's perfect this is nice that's it
let's do it pour of an ounce right there
so this is acting as our bittering agent
which is looking good yeah so we're
gonna set an anchor so 2 whole cube not
3 I said 2 so we theoretically wash
their hands before this we definitely
did we got it right well whatever we're
drinking I don't see you guys can you
just grab two cubes we're gonna gently
set them in nice and light there we go
look at you guys so let's break them so
we're adding now surface area we want to
get some dollars and I like the way you
splash if we just dumped in only these
whole you would end up with not enough
surface area the drink would get cold
before it was properly diluted if we
dumped in all broken ice the drink would
get way diluted before it was ever cold
now we're gonna set in like three or
four more you're just gonna cap it off
using our two fingers and we're just
we're just going back and forth nice and
gentle you pretty much already got it
which is amazing you're hired
I've never seen anyone get it that fast
but this guy right here
or this little [ __ ] still over this
finger Dahlia struggling you are not a
good lover
other than that miss before I've also
heard that in the for thanks
let's stop leave your spoon in there
let's hang out because as we're stirring
we're agitating a little bit we're
increasing dye Lucien but we also want
to get it nice and cold so we're putting
it in a classic cocktail goblet the
reason for that is you don't want a lot
of surface area for it to warm up in for
most people this is a bit of a garish
class when you say garish well it means
that you get to go look in the
dictionary it would be like an adjective
right okay whatever yeah we're gonna
strain this off right out of the pint
glass and into the glass mmm very nice
our finishing touch is gonna be an
orange twist we're gonna start at the
top go all the way down
boom boom just shooting the oils out
over the top of the drink planning it a
little on the rim so this is the stylus
a 50:50 martini at the medium our team
Los Angeles
oh yeah mines good yours is gonna taste
weird what you should try on right yeah
this is good you nailed it all right
yeah if you get these classic recipes do
them at home you can make martinis you
can make Manhattan's you can make better
than what you'd get up a lot of times
choose the bar your sport bar to
reinitiate it thank you guys thanks for
coming by
thank you